like like i remember because i was i was
in i was in this i was in this
restaurant and we uh we missed the fact
that shidaka was part of the course
because it was like it was like this um
it was like this like seven course meal
um
yeah it was a sperm sock and um
this hotel we were staying at we missed
the part there was shiraka there and
they put it in front of us uh to in uh
like with me and sydney right yeah and i
was just like
oh
oh no it's this thing right and cindy
doesn't know what it is and i'm just
like i'm just like let her read it i'm
just like do i tell her or do i not and
uh
and uh i i i unfortunately i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm a loving partner i did tell her
no
because right she's not gonna eat it's
not gonna eat it yeah i i thought she
was like me right i thought she'd be
like you know what i'll still eat it
because it's japanese culture i i wanna
i wanna you know i wanna
show respect right and she's like i'm
not [ __ ] it
i'm not [ __ ]
this is after me psyching myself up
right and and i'm just like okay
i can deep throat this i'm i'm a deep
throat in this [ __ ] sperm sac right
now my favorite metal gear
so i'm just like oh
i take it i like swallow in one
isn't it like a string like isn't it
like a bunch it's like it's like a bunch
right so so well it's like it's like
swallowing a fallopian tube yeah yeah
yeah yeah basically so so it is like a
bunch but like i i found a way to like
[ __ ] expand my throat i i channeled
all my inner jojo
at that point man i'm just like i'm a
deep throat this and one and i [ __ ]
didn't look
all right it's done
sydney all right you do yours and she's
like have it i'm like sydney eat it i'm
like i'm not gonna [ __ ] eat it i'm
like you want to tell the people i'm not
gonna eat it i'm like i'm not telling
people we're we're gonna finish our
[ __ ] food we're not gonna show
disrespect and she was like do it you
can do it i'm just like
no
i'm not gonna do it and it was just like
a [ __ ] game of chicken
do it
eat eat the sperm
you eat it and in the end i'm just like
fine i'll [ __ ] do it
and on that day i deep throated two fish
sperm sacks
and i never want to do it again because
you know what that [ __ ] did not feel
that [ __ ] did not sit right in my
stomach man but okay here's the question
though are you the type of person who
gets conceptually grossed out by food no
i i don't just off the premise alone i i
won't ever have like a a yes or no
answer to either right so if you if i
never told you ever that shirako was
sperm it's slimy it's too slimy
it's too creamy it has this really weird
aftertaste that that that is what like
set my stomach is creamy
it's creamy yeah it was great it was
really creamy
surprisingly he is really really [ __ ]
creamy it's creamy it's viscosity
okay yes yes yes you know what the taste
and the texture of shirako is exactly
what you think it is
what can i say it's creamy it's slimy
it's viscous what should i call just a
fancy name it's fish nut yeah i i can
the thing that i have just realized my
weakness is slime like anything that is
slimy i really struggle you're not the
first person though right
and i don't know like
clearly i just haven't been raised to
eat slimy things like i never had slimy
things in my life yeah i thought i wish
i did because i feel like i've been
debuff but that's the thing like that's
why i don't blame anyone who doesn't
like things like okra or not or
anything like that because if you didn't
grow up with that [ __ ] it's like eating
so to me it is like too close to the
consistency of snot yeah yeah and like
when you go to a real man
you get it gone you deep throat
so when you go to a real can right you
get a meal like a set meal in japan
right you get a lot of food and it's
always like so i'm gonna i'm gonna just
call it like levels no not courses it's
like level one through three right it's
always the most painful because they
just it's always cold and it's always
slimy food that comes from first i don't
know why they've done this it's like
they're trying to like not all of it are
slimy okay some of it's slimy yeah i've
been to some places where they were like
they were like for some reason some guy
woke up and was like every meal must
have slime like i went to one ryokan and
i was like every meal i was like i can't
wait for the next one i wonder what
it'll be turns out more slime stuff and
i'm like come on i can't get a win man
but like always there's at least like
you get like you get like four little
dishes two of them will be cold jelly or
slimy guaranteed i don't know why i
don't know why they're obsessed with
putting slimy stuff japan is weirdly
japan is weirdly obsessed with the jelly
they're like a nickelodeon kid bro it's
like you they they have more slime than
them i don't understand
the japanese are the only ones who watch
nickelodeon guts went and looks
delicious yeah
they're like they're like seeing this
nickelodeon slime being pulled out like
[ __ ] they're wasting so much food
eat it
yeah i don't know it's like we do have
like very traditional japanese foods are
either slimy or gelatinous it's a shame
because i really wanna i really wanna
give it a good go and i eat it most of
the time but with much pain with great
difficulty and again it's i feel that i
absolutely do not blame anyone who
doesn't like that side of japanese
cuisine because it is a tall hurdle
especially if you weren't raised on it
right right yeah i like i i feel i i can
confidently say that i would not like
natto or okra or you know anything
gelatinous or anything like that if i
didn't grow up with it yeah just because
yeah the first time you put it in your
mouth it's like this shouldn't be in my
mouth
this should be up someone's nose
you know it's and it's like it is like
discomforting it's weird because it's
like something
i'm like no something grilled okay yeah
okay
yeah exactly right i mean i like cold
things it's just
slimy things you know that's just but
and normally things that i don't like or
what's worse a hot slimy thing or a cold
slime you think
what's hot slime you think
what is a hot slime you think dish i
don't you put natto in a microwave
that just like accentuates the [ __ ]
smell that sounds horrible oh my god can
you imagine microwaving natto you do
isn't it like dude
packs right yeah because it comes frozen
so you have to microwave it right you
better like been done
what
frozen
alien's angry because someone bought
frozen natto yep disgusting yeah that's
why i put it in a microwave mainly
something has just set male 1 off
i've never heard maylene interrupt an
episode that is the first time i've
heard malin interrupted if she wants to
interrupt she'll hold a sign that says
incest but microwave natto that's where
she draws the line that's why she has to
step in i'm gonna let you finish
you know that's the thing is that yeah
it sucks most of these like gelatinous
or slimy dishes are so goddamn healthy
yeah yeah and they have so much good
stuff here i'm like damn i wish i could
i